thanks everybody uh I'm Chrisman from uh
from synthesis uh so let's talk about
parallel
education uh let's see oh here we go
okay great um so yeah my uh my
co-founder Josh uh started a school for
for Elon Musk at uh at SpaceX for elon's
kids and some of the other SpaceX
families and you know I think a lot of
people were really excited about this
they got a lot of attention um because
you know maybe this is going to be
elon's next coming and he was going to
fix education for us uh but he really
just wanted the school for his own kids
and so you know Josh and I kind of
realized if we're going to fix education
you know it would be up to us and so we
uh we started a company uh to kind of
scale up the innovative ideas from that
school and make them available to people
who uh you know aren't billionaires with
their own rocket company but still want
the best education for their
kids and I think it's uh it's just
important to reflect for a second like
why does someone like Elon who's who's
clearly got a lot to do um you know what
what makes him care about education I
think it comes down to this fundamental
thing that education is about values
people find it uh very uncomfortable to
uh have their kids educated by someone
who who doesn't precisely share their
values and elon's not alone there I
think the the kind of like the falling
trust that we see in the system which is
already quite low um is driven at least
partially uh by this values conflict and
I think by the way that we are
absolutely right uh to fight over the
values in our education systems uh
because the values that we embody in
education uh become the civilizations
that we create our civilizations are
Downstream of Education uh so two very
different societies here ancient Sparta
and Athens uh the Spartan system very
rigid it's kind of designed to get
people to fight in this failan and you
know the idea is like you have the right
answer and you need to just execute then
this rigidity is okay uh but of course
the Spartans uh you know are gone now
and our civilization is much more based
on the ancient Athenians who had a more
open-minded approach the idea that you
don't you're not in possession of the
truth but you can come closer to it and
by doing so you can make
progress I said the values of synthesis
are you know essentially that there's
there's knowledge and wisdom in the past
that we want to pass on and and there's
Beauty there as well um but we don't
want to pass those things on so we can
return to some past we want to actually
move forward and make progress and
continue to create uh new and and
wondrous
things uh so in a word uh you know
building things is good actually and for
the people in this room this might seem
obvious and and
uncontroversial uh but you know it's uh
there's this idea that's kind of endemic
in the system now um I just pulled this
one headline from Oregon but I could
pull dozens like this from from around
the world uh where where people kind of
have this Zero Sum mentality that if
some people learn and Excel that that
comes at the expense of everybody else
and that is a uh that that's that's a
zero sum way of looking at the world and
if it's left unchecked it will keep us
all um equally ignorant and and
impoverished and and will destroy
civilization so you you can think about
this in terms of of B's question you
know do do you go for loyalty Voice or
or exit and loyalty is really tough when
you don't share the values of the system
uh so so what people like Gary are
trying to do here is is voice and you
know I I admire the hoods Spa but I
think it's going to be really tough when
people are kind of hellbent on not
teaching math and science the idea that
you're going to make them uh sort of do
it by force uh and that they're going to
be somehow really good at it I you know
I think that's going to be really tough
uh so there there's this other approach
which uh which Tesla has kind of shown
us the way on this which is sort of a um
you know like a voice through exit so
the idea there is you build something
just that's wildly better than the
current system and uh and maybe you can
get the system then to to pay attention
and to adapt and change the way the car
companies have embraced electric
vehicles so uh you know back to what
we're we're actually building um the the
the uh you know one of elon's critiques
of the system which I think is really
good is that uh you know the the way
that school does it is they would kind
of give you like a course on on wrenches
and a course on screwdrivers that kind
of teach to the tool instead of the
problem and what you should actually do
is just give kids an engine to take
apart and then that way when they reach
for the tool there's meaning there
there's a much more engaging and
effortless way to
learn so the way they approach this at
the SpaceX school is you put kids in
teams because most problem solving
happens in teams the problems we're all
working on I imagine we have to work
together with a team you put them in
teams they have to collaborate there and
they compete with other teams which
gives us this fun kind of you know
competitive Spirit to it and you're
giving the kids these complex problems
that are in the forms of of games and
and simulations and the problems are
fake but they feel real to the kids and
there feels like there's some real
Stakes to them and we use this as a
platform to teach them the kind of meta
problem solving skills so the things
that that we're all using every day how
do you communicate effectively how do
you work together how do you make
decisions under uncertainty and uh and
learn from the environment and adapt and
the kids really love it and when I when
I saw this at the SpaceX school I was
just blown away everyone who sees it
kind of has the same reaction you just
can't believe the remarkable skills that
these kids can develop at a young age
and this is initially what made me uh
feel like we had to start a company and
scale this up so this is sort of an idea
that is uh you know orthogonal to the
existing system it's it's uh very much
outside the system it's not really
stepping on any toes uh so let's talk
about the next thing we have which is a
product called uh tutor which is is more
a direct uh shot across the bow and I
think uh biology captures the spirit of
that uh pretty pretty well here so the
idea is you can uh you know replace the
the woke teachers with uh with AI uh
teachers or or you know actually even
better uh tutors uh tutoring is uh is
Far and Away the best way to learn so
there is a researcher called uh Benjamin
Bloom who coined this idea the Bloom's
two Sigma problem and uh you the idea
there is that uh you can take kids with
tutoring from 50th to 99th percentile
which kind of the difference between uh
Community College and and the ivy league
we can do this with tutoring and and we
can't really do it any other way the
elites have always known this which is
why Alexander the Great was tutored by
Aristotle and of course the problem is
uh you know there's not enough
aristotles to go around and all the
efforts the kind of Holy Grail of
Education technology is to create a
digital Aristotle Aristotle that we can
uh use to reach every kid
uh so this is uh this is data from a
DARPA project they spent about hundred
million trying to create a digital tutor
and I don't have time to go in the data
here but uh if you Google uh less wrong
uh DARPA tutor then then you can do a
deep dive on that the upshot of it for
now is that they tried to solve blooms 2
Sigma problem and for the US Navy to
teach people it and they accidentally
overshot it by about an order of
magnitude so not only can we have uh
digital tutors that are as effective as
the best human tutors but we can have
something that's far far better and
let's see if I can do a quick uh I I'll
play a little video for you guys can you
fill out the whole table now give it a
try so
wait let's take a look at the
highlighted square and start there go
ahead and fill it out when you're ready
um okay look carefully at what pieces
you've put into the square and note how
you've read them first then columns
let's do the same thing with this larger
Square now * two that doesn't make sense
good I'll unlock the rest of the widget
for you to continue filling it keep an
eye out for those tricky rows and
columns so going
to four *
two
so in the four and
then two oh yeah um 2 * 5 okay that's
not how that's not the right time okay
let's take a look at the two highlighted
squares it's just a convention but for
this table we'll read the pieces as Rose
times columns go ahead and swap them to
make sure they're on the correct spot
okay so let going the
colum wow amazing work you're on top of
this I think I get the P you have
probably noticed that I colored the dots
in a bit of a strange way how many dots
are there of each
color all right so you can uh you guys
can give this a try for yourself what I
want to point out uh there is you can
see that the the kids really like it and
and they like it because it's not boring
it's giving them something to do and
then when they make mistakes it's sort
of jumping in and probing for their
misconceptions and helping them to guide
themselves to the answers and you the
evidence from these the DARPA trials
where they pioneered this approach is
that you can learn about 20x faster uh
this way so you can speedrun the system
uh so try it out for yourselves uh
there's a free demo up here and if you
have kids uh then uh you can sign up at
synthesis uh.com and that's that's my
time thank
you